democrats whine too much chuck
just quit being a whiny party you know
that ted cruz cruz guy
seems like a real stiff
but at least he believes in the concept
of shopping with money it's not my fault
that the party of fdr and jfk is turning
into the party of lol and wtf
members of congress
tweeting things like cancel rent
cancel mortgage and
no more policing or incarceration
crazy right bill maher is 100 right the
democratic party is not the party of
kennedy roosevelt anymore
now it's the party of free housing big
government climate emergencies and
social spending projects that continue
to increase the deficit as we speak it's
now over 30 trillion dollars things have
certainly changed since the 1990s
remember
it doesn't matter whether or not they're
the victims of society the end result is
they're about to knock my mother on the
head with a lead pipe shoot my sister
beat up my wife take on my sons
so i don't want to ask
what made them do this
they must be taken off the street the
submission of the first balanced budget
in 30 years one that will truly
strengthen our nation for the 21st
century
this budget marks the end of an era
an end to decades of deficits that have
shackled our economy
democrats i know you know that joining
us now to discuss the change jim justice
governor of west virginia in 2017 he
switched parties from democrat to
republican and recently won re-election
as a gopro and new jersey congressman
jeff van drew he switched parties from
democrat to republican in 2020 and won
re-election in the blue state of new
jersey as a republican so guys welcome
thanks so much for joining us you heard
those clips earlier
governor
did the party leave you or did you leave
the party
no question in my book brian the party
left me you know i worked really really
hard on getting a budget passed i went
back and forth between the democrats and
republicans over and over and over i
finally got it where it was really great
for everybody but especially great for
the democrats and then they just dove in
a ditch i made this decision really
quickly you know really after seven
months of this there's no way in the
world i'm gonna sit down here just to
play games i wanted to get something
done and so really i you know i went
home i talked to my wife i said i can't
take this i just cannot take this and
everything so the next person i saw i
went to the oval office and sat down
with president trump because we're great
friends friends of the family i thought
he did a fabulous job beyond belief i
look forward to him being back there and
absolutely in every way but i sat there
and i looked right at him and i said mr
president i'm thinking about changing
parties honest to goodness is true if i
drop dead this very minute he jumped
across the table stuck his hand out like
that and said do it jim do it right now
and then he yelled mike mike get in here
and then mike pence came in and then he
said you know rents come and come in
here and and and so all of a sudden he
came in and and lo and behold you know
we were all sitting there and having a
little uh a little semi-celebration but
uh but the long long and short shirt of
it is uh you know uh
you know that's the first person i told
i did that because of respect for him
and all the great stuff that i knew that
he was going to do and lo and behold
it's the best decision i've ever made
and congressman you had a similar story
i know a similar background you changed
about the same time but if your part if
the democratic party were looking to get
the deficit to zero and crack down on
crime you might not have made that
decision right
well it wouldn't have been the
democratic party that we have now the
party that you see now is the democratic
socialist party the democratic marxist
party uh this is not really what i think
is a good american party and yes it was
a similar story i wouldn't vote for
impeachment i was the one democrat that
wouldn't vote for it and under
tremendous pressure i had a lot of
important people speak to me and i
remember the fatal words when they said
to me literally
you will obey they said that to me well
they they don't know folks from jersey
and they don't know me so i didn't
really know what i was going to do i
walked home that day after a lot of you
know unhappy dialogue and discussions uh
realizing and i've realized for a while
this is not just happening today this
has been going on for a number of years
uh and didn't well i got a call from the
white house the long and short of it and
again it is similar president trump
wanted to meet with me we sat and talked
believe it or not for about an hour and
a half and he turned to me and he said
congressman
you should be a republican and i turned
to him and said mr president i am going
to be a republican same thing with
jumping up the only thing is i hadn't
told anybody at home yet so
because he wanted to do it right then
right there
doing a couple days i have to go home
tell my wife tell my kids just you know
gotcha get everybody set and they were
all good and it was an amazing time
and i won re-election i'm proud i did it
we have to take this country back this
is more than just the names of political
parties this is about the future of
america we are in the precipice we are
about to lose this great nation we are
the shining city on the hill we are the
greatest
outcomes i want to get the governor in
one last time governor okay um
if the president governed as a moderate
he would be much more formidable along
with his party some would say in 2022
and 2024 much like a guy a senator
mansion from your state a moderate
democrat do you think he will today
brian and you know this and your great
friend and i can tell you with all
without any doubt
what's happening with the national
democratic party is complete insanity
and we know it i mean for cry it surely
wasn't anything close to that bad in
west virginia but what's going on now is
an absolute circus well uh well a fellow
democrat helped save the country senator
joe manchin i believe uh thanks governor
congressman best of luck hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else